welcome to this video and this is in
fact blitz video number 1000 1000 quite
remarkable okay we got a Vienna game and
of course I have forgotten what what I'm
playing here think is this line and I'm
really hoping to not screw it up I
didn't get check a celebrity opponent
for game thousand game one had a corona
camera it was quite funny okay what is
this
I completely crazy this position if i
take f3 enters good check and now i take
g two and half I have queen age for
Kevin queen edge form
check funny but not clear not clear at
all shakey's got Queenie to in some way
to protect the power this would be very
nice maybe in Queen g5 and Bishop e6 to
d5 or something like that I don't I
don't see a direct win Bishop g4 21
seems to defend this Bishop is a
nuisance it really keeps the position to
channel okay
yeah yeah I can't play b3 King be too it
looks strange but it can do that
maybe King b2 b3 King b2c for drifting
driving driving my bishop the way oh
he's actually allowing this with temple
yeah well I don't mind that hmm
Jim
I don't know what is the sand cam it
shouldn't be too bad if i go very
quickly with ah this move but i can go
to f3 this is not necessarily a problem
this is very strange very strange test
hmm pretty sure and that was something
better yeah this looks very nice from it
looks nice but but but what is it what
is it actually doing
hmm i'd like to open up the position of
course something like rook here rook age
6 + f6 and so this would be nice or king
here and then f6 I know coming let's
let's let's play this directly no more
straightforward fashion yeah he's got
some pawns as well mmm i686 he should
play six takes rook e1
oh wow check this I didn't expect
he can maybe go to age form
and wait wait wait we just hormone if I
play
hmm I was thinking of playing age for
pawn to age for here and he can take
with the pawn this is actually the
problem
okay let's not think about this too much
I'm threatening knowledge Wow hmm
and of course is playing all this
instantly
yeah the rook has no square this is very
cool
okay then I need to secure the square
for if you take that play age three and
win this is what I had thought about you
earlier this idea to to second so when
it wasn't for nothing this time spent
hm I have no idea what's going on
absolutely no idea rook GNA it looks
like i have some attack but where's the
maid
check
should be form
hmm it's not too made
roo k 3 is a strong move now Luke a
three ah mmm this will hurt yeah and of
course you finds it
ah what a set game for Game one thousand
being completely winning in the opening
and then spoiling it hmm yeah I have no
move here time morning black resigns
yeah it's a one-off one of those games
where you really don't know what what
happened to you I mean isn't this this
must be good for black computers that
are completely unimpressed then he went
for a giant game yeah well maybe and it
was just invading with the king like no
tomorrow he six was was John obvious but
here why I just I overlooked that age
for was actually a good nice idea but he
just played all the right moves Qing Yi
six is winning here King is six but with
probably a mated mating attack yeah all
i had read what i did this i completely
overlooked okay three which wins
instantly I can play rookie three or
whatever and have a game you can briefly
check in e6 which is the winner with
rook g8 coming if he plays let's say
this for example there's this one check
and he's so he's out of out of default
of defense yeah yeah you feel that this
should be a problem with the skin
position of it just blundered with you
three with g3 the doctor this is it's
really gone no no way I'd ever at all
like this everything's hanging quite a
quite amazing but this means that in the
opening
I probably should play differently I
mean this is not looking bad at all I
mean the night is it doesn't have any
square the Vienna game in this form is
serve is simply simply a sub by opening
but then yeah what a plate looked so so
nice but it's probably yet probably not
really decisive can also think about the
check here check but now you don't
really have a good move no it's always
this is still a good piece preventing my
castling so it's not not easy okay
thanks for watching and for lots of here
thanks for watching the videos before
that a bit of a sad game or game
thousand but I'm honest with you this
was game thousand and not some game I
had to prepare and reserved for this
occasion thanks for watching